Element 113 is, again, labelled with this
new systematic
method for the artificial elements. So you
have un-un-trium
or it might be ununtrium, I don’t know,
which stands for 113.
And you might actually ask, ‘Why should
anybody want to
make a few atoms of these artificial elements?’
And I think
the answer, I don’t know definitely, is
that there have been
predictions that although the elements at
this part of the
periodic table are very unstable, that there
may, at heavier
elements, be one or two elements which are
surprisingly
stable, might last for very much longer. They
are called
‘islands of stability’ that have been
predicted, and so people
are working systematically to see whether
in fact there are
one or two elements that are in fact really
quite stable even
though they are super heavy. And when I was
a young
researcher in the 1970s, somebody, I can’t
remember who it
was, got very excited because they thought
in remnants of
very ancient mineral mica, it’s a sort of
mineral that comes
in layers, that they found some strange patterns,
which they
thought was an indication of super heavy elements
decaying,
perhaps as heavy as element 164. Enormously
heavier than
anything anybody has been able to create in
the lab. It turned
out not to be as exciting as they thought
and there was some
other completely different explanation. But
it is testing
theories and things like that that really
move science forward.